[Music]
today's question comes from victoria in
texas
victoria writes my fiance will finish
his medical residency this year
he has a hundred and fifty thousand
dollars in student loans nine grand in
credit card debt
and no emergency fund when we first met
he always said that the best investment
you could make is paying off your debt
but his priorities have now changed he
makes
he makes minimum payments on the credit
card deferred the student loans
and allocates the rest of his money drum
roll please
to cryptocurrency i have a little throw
up in my mouth
it is crazy i promise he promises that
he'll start paying off debt as soon as
his residency ends
but it worries me that he prefers to
invest in something that's risky rather
than paying off his debt
should i be concerned about this new
obsession or should i trust that he will
eventually make his debt a priority
man so anytime somebody says hey this is
a
important thing for me and you go great
and then they change it on you
and they do something different and then
they say hey but next time
but next time you can trust me and then
that changes again
yes you should be concerned about the
integrity of the person that you're
walking alongside
yes you should be concerned i think
i absolutely do actually in fact the
more i think about this the more
frustrating this gets
because you've got a scared fiance here
and you've got somebody who has some
wisdom in one area of life
i think you guys getting this
straightened out prior to marriage
is a deal breaker i agree um and that's
sitting down with your pre-marriage
counselor
and coming to terms with a uh
you're no longer aligned on how money is
handled and b
he's changed his mind i'll tell you what
i think has happened and
a good spanking in the marriage
counselor's office will fix it uh
because he's going to get to trade
choose between you and crypto um
if you're my daughter and um uh
so not because i hate crypto but because
of this whole the way he's doing this in
his whole process
so my experience of coaching is
people with their finances
there are more broke doctors
medical doctors than any other thing i
run into
i mean we see all the broke athletes are
broke music people
they make all their money and then they
lose it all but broke doctors hide it
behind a bmw with a lease payment
and so people don't realize how bad
their finances are and when i've sat
down with them over the years
they're unbelievably suck at how they
handle their money
that says about to say you get there's
an arrogance built in right that's
exactly why
i can take a heart out so surely i know
surely i can
do cryptocurrency right and so what i
smell
is a young medical student who took his
class on i am now god i'm a doctor
and i know everything and so he got he
got downloaded the arrogant
download and uh
that a good spanking in the therapist's
office will fix that or a good spanking
in the market we'll fix it too yeah but
i don't want him i don't want to be
attached i don't
have taken her down when she you know
you don't want to go down with a
drowning guy here
because he because but here's the thing
it's not
what he's doing but why he's doing it
that's the deal breaker because
if i'm right if he is doing if he
changed from his common sense when he
was humble
to now i'm arrogant and so i can play
things that
other people can't play and i will come
out which every time you play in a high
risk thing that's
that's involved right you have to think
you've got the edge on something that no
one else does i've got the ticket on
this horse
so i can bet the farm at this horse race
you know and
i've got an edge and and you because and
arrogance is what this is it's pride
pride comes right before the fall
so the the that's what's the deal
breaker because when it's not crypto
it's going to be something
else it's going to be an it's going to
be another thing and he's going to go
buy into a pizza chain
and that's going to go broke and then
he's going to go buy fried pickles
and then he's going to do because he's
always because he's so
freaking smart that
is a deal breaker right because you're
going to live a life
of bull crap sucky decisions
to bullcrap sucky decisions to bullcrap
sucky decisions
it's just going to be one after another
until this pride is broken
i know this guy because i was him as was
i that's what i i keep saying
victoria i am this guy right i know a
lot of stuff about a really small this
is how
dave ramsey went broke yeah because i am
inordinately good with math
i can see things i can see a deal i can
feel
math when it's on a piece of paper i i
i'm not good at a lot of stuff but
so i could walk into a real estate deal
and ding ding ding ding and i can tell
you today 35 years later exactly what i
paid for that property
what we spent on it and what i made on
it they just those numbers are stored i
can't get them out of my head
i see them they're on a chalkboard in my
mind you know
and so because i thought i was so such
all that uh that i went and built a
dadgum house of cards and it came
crashing down on guess what my wife and
my kids had
so i often find when i'm in one of these
arrogant modes or when i'm with folks
like this and i've spent a lot of times
behind closed doors of medical folks
they can feel or sense that deal
they can't feel or sense the person they
love sitting at them in the driver's
seat suddenly feeling like they just
their their lifeline just got yep it got
got cut right yep
and yeah i'm with you the scary thing
about this victoria is this is a pattern
that i've seen
over and over and over and over so if he
can become one of the
smartest doctors that is humble and
realizes he's good at medicine
and sucks at money and needs to do basic
grandma common sense with money if he
can revisit that lying
line that's an indication he has become
humble
rather than prideful and that is
marriage material yeah
but it's not the detail of
cryptocurrency versus
paying off your student loans that's not
the detail that's not the deal breaker
it's the why
under it that is a reason not to marry
this guy
absolutely until you get this fixed and
so
that that's because you're gonna you're
signing up for a lifetime of heartache
yeah and crap falling down around your
head because i
man i tell you the number of doctors
who've earned four
fortunes and only have one yeah um
with three wives too right yeah yeah and
two husbands
and you we when we do this stuff when
we're arrogant and we we drag our
families through the same thing
and they they get to go along for the
ride and uh
you know i say you know i used to say
well you know sharon was really afraid
when we were going through all this and
she would go no
the word is terrified not because of the
situation
but because you kept doing it
terrified i terrified my wife
victoria you're terrified i can see it
in on the page here
and you should be